welcome back everybody it is now time
for this week's pet project amy lee
joins us from the nspca and she brought
along someone who needs a safe and
caring home and this one is a cat named
majesty she is royalty
he he really is excuse me he
the majesty is a beautiful handsome
five-year-old boy um and we haven't
wrapped it up burrito because he's a
little he's being a little sassy today
and he doesn't really want to help you
know cats are can be a little fussy and
that's totally okay and majesty royalty
you know it just comes along with the
name
exactly
it is looking for a wonderful home he
has mild stomatitis which is really uh
really common it's actually something
that spc will take care of um so you
would just speak to one of our adoption
counselors about it but he's a really
wonderful cat um he is a maine [ __ ] mix
he is really sweet you know once he gets
to know you he's a little bit shy at
first but once he gets to know you he's
a doll and he just wants to come and
love be loved on he loves treats so we
hope to find him a really loving home
soon oh with that condition what kind of
home is best for majesty
you know really he's a pretty easy cat
you know mature children we ask for you
know family that's not doesn't have
small small kids because he can be a
little bit fussy but in adult flight
home is totally fine for him he's really
good to go okay and will majesty be
featured in the calendar that you
mentioned
well the calendar is actually going to
be for
you the public so if you've got a pet
dog a cat a rabbit guinea pig or a rat
we want you to enter our second annual
nevada spca calendar contest um just
visit our website to the events page and
you'll be able to upload your photo and
you'll get a copy of the calendar but
we're trying to raise money for our
shelter and for our shelter animals for
animals like majesty oh that's such a
great cause and if someone adopts
majesty from this segment you know
there's still time to get majesty in the
calendar right
a hundred percent
why not so
amy
amy tell us really quick how we can
adopt a pet from you guys
very easy just visit our website
nevadaspca.org you're just going to go
to the adoptable cat page there's a
green button at the top just click that
button and schedule your appointment all
right thank you so much amy bye majesty
all right if you're interested in
adopting a pet just go to
nevadaspca.org or call them at
702-873-7722